Tôi đồng nhẹp kiế đến đây, ông Trump đã lên tục công bú những mức thuy mới với hãng hoa nhất khẩu.
Thuy đối ứng, tỉ mới phần chup, rồi đến thuy bộ xuống theo mục máy lấy một.
Bệ thuy nhất khẩu bộ xuống vào có hiệu được thực chất là gì và được tính toàn như thế nào?
Chức tin hệ cùng tìm hiểu, thuyên quan hoạt lợp như thế nào?
Thuyên quan là quản thuyế, nãy lên thằng hoa nhất khẩu, dân nhập nhập khẩu, ra bên độc thuyế,
hãy từng tượng một công ty mi, nhập một chiếc máy giặt từ hành Quốc, với giả là năm 2018,
nếu Mỹ á thuy hành quý phần chăm, ông tìm nghiệp khẩu sẽ phải nục thuyên một chăm USB cho chính phủ Mỹ.
Thuy đức thuộc của khẩu, khoản tin đó, thương đục cộng vào giả bán.
Đó là cách thuyên quan hoạt lợp.
Giả cao hơn, cũng có thể khiến cho dành nghiệp nhập nhập khẩu ít hàng hơn.
Ông Trump cho rằng bằng cách làm cho hàng nghiệp khẩu đắt hơn, chính giách này,
cuộc người rất phẹy yêu tiên dùng hàng của Mỹ và huyên phyết tắt răng nghiệp,
mở nhà máy cũng như là tạo thêm việc làm cho nước.
Sản định giám ơn, The United States will implement reciprocal tariffs.
Chào, chào, chào, chào, chào, chào, chào, chào, chào, chào.
Đặc malen thay đổi cư sở pháp liy, nhằm tình cách át phy dễ dậu đối với hóa nhất không?
Đặc lợp quyền hạp tình tỉ hình cấp quốc tế, hãy ý ý viê.
Nếu khoản 1,2,3 và 1 nhất là điều khoản bác chăm lệ 1.
A以 EBA, đây là khoản thời lưỡi, mà ốc Trump có bố và đăng hàng nghiệp 2.0.
A mời, đến năm 2019, tối hơn 1,3 mươi nền kỹ tế.
Tì nhiên, thẳng 2 vừa qua, tỏ ăn tối cao Mỹ đã trạm bất tủy này.
Này sau đó, ngày 2020, thẳng 2, 2 ím khuôn trăm 2,5 bí, 5 ím chiến trăm 1,5 mươi tư.
Này át thuyện nguyện phần chăm, tối tuần bụ hàng nhập khẩu, chăm 1,5 mươi.
Bá hết hạn, và ngày 2020, 5 ím khuôn trăm 2,5 mươi tụng 1,5 mươi tụng 1,5 mươi tụng 1,5 mươi tụng 1,5 mươi.
Lập tức được nươi ra cho xong miệnh kinh tế, dựa trên 1,5 mươi một, của đặc lột thương 1,5 mươi tụng 1,5 mươi tụng.
Bởi chính sách mới nhất, Mỹ chia sống bên dành tình tế xa làm ba nhóm, với ba cách tình thuy khác nhau.
Nó một át thuy bộ xúc của định mươi phần chăm, vô mùi bẩy nên kinh tế, phí dụng, độ, indonesia, ekua đỏ, tình bân.
Các tính, phuy bộ xúc vơi phần chăm, cộng chực tiếp tế lên thuy mươi f nè, tức là mức thuy quan tưu trình hiện hành.
Nó 2 át dụng trình thuy vơi phần chăm hoặc mươi 2,5 mươi tụng tế ngất, phần chăm tình gước, phần chân lập lịch giữa mức chân này.
Bà thuy tối hệ quốc, áp dụng với nâm liên trình tế, EU, Nhật Bản, Hàn Quốc, Kuy Xị và Đài Loan, nhóm ma, át thuy bộ xúc của định nguyai 2 phy năm vân chăm.
Tổng chực tiếp lên thuy tối hệ quốc vệ hành, vùng ba mì tạm liên trình tế khận lại trong đó có chung Quốc, Thái Lan và Việt Nam.
Thuy ba trong lệ một át lên hầu hết hành hoặc nhập khầu từ sống mươi nên trình tế, máo khủ khoảng trình mới trình phy bụng vân chăm, tổng chiếm hệ kẹp khầu và Mỹ.
Thuy nhiên, cô phải tất cả hành hoặc của Việt Nam, xuất hổ sang Mỹ đều triệu mức thuy là mùi 2 phy năm vân chăm.
Các nống hàng chú lực, chiếm tối năm 2019 tìm chăm xúc khẩu của Việt Nam, máo quốc, máy tính, sản phẩm địa từ và lịch kiện.
Mấy mắc, tiếp định dụng cụ vụt thung, giận thoại và lịch kiện, không bị át phy bụng xúc lên này.
Bòn các ngành nghe khác sẽ bị tính như sau, phy xuất khẩu sang Mỹ sẽ bằng thuy tối hệ quốc, cộng với cả thuy bụng xúc, mùi 2 phy năm vân chăm.
Thuy dụng đồ về mất hàng vịch mây, mức thuy tối hệ quốc, già người xóo phân chăm và với đợi đợi đợi lần này, thuy tối hệ quốc, cộng với thuy bụng xúc, mùi 2 phy năm vân chăm.
Sẽ ra 2 phy năm vân chăm. Bị đã đạt được vui chính to ở thận không, họ kìa định thương mại đo癮.
Bây nhiên thời gian trời chân ra, Mỹ cầu xuất hiện thêm các mức thuy mối vẫn còn.
Chính rất này, sẽ không viên mất, chừng nèo ở của đối nhà chẳng.